hi there Steve Kaufman here talking to
all of you who want to learn languages
and I you know I'm very happy to share
with you my experience my views and I
think my views should count for
something because I have learned 12
languages to varying degrees have
another two that I'm working on and yet
my views I think are very much in the
minority okay I'm going to talk today
about active and passive vocabulary and
I'm gonna say that there is far too much
emphasis placed both in terms of how we
teach languages and the things that
people worry about when they learn
languages there's too much emphasis on
active vocabulary it's this old question
of you know developing an ability to
speak or rather focusing on building up
your understanding of the language it is
impossible to be fluent if you can't
understand it is possible it is
impossible to claim that you are at some
level they have all these numbers B 1 T
B 2 C 1 whatever you claim you can't
claim that you speak at that level if
you don't understand at a much higher
level because the native speaker with
whom you're gonna speak is always going
to have a bigger vocabulary than you do
you have to understand what that person
is saying what's more in any language
even our own we usually spend more time
listening than we do speaking you've got
to understand what people are saying
around you what are they doing
classrooms they try to force people to
speak speak correctly and I think I read
something recently about how anything
that we cram will only stay in our
short-term memory anything that we learn
against the green is only going to stay
in our short-term memory things that we
acquire through regular and enjoyable
repetition is going to stay with us and
that is why our language
earning method that is based on lots of
listening and reading I know I'm a bit
repetitious on this it's gonna stay with
you you're gonna be able to revive and
refresh those languages easily as I have
done with my Italian which I haven't
touched for the longest time and then a
couple of weeks of listening and reading
talking a little bit with our tutors at
linking and it comes back stronger than
ever before because it's in there
soundly because it's built up based on
this very large passive vocabulary there
was a talk at Ted that showed up on my
YouTube channel you know how they
recommend things for you to watch and
there's this fellow okay maybe I'll put
a link here but this linguistics person
saying things which I considered simply
to be untrue he said the biggest
obstacle people have in language
learning is their fear of not being able
to speak and the way around that is you
just don't need so many words you just
need a few key words and then you can
speak but you won't understand anything
that's an even worse situation to me the
biggest fear I have is not understanding
what people are saying to me so you know
it just as a matter of defensiveness in
order that when we do speak I mean
there's no question that when you speak
you are going to struggle stumble it's
embarrassing you can't say what you want
all of those things for sure but if you
at least understand what the person is
saying if you have a large passive
vocabulary you're going to do better
you're gonna understand better and now
you have some time with less pressure to
try and use you know try to activate
some of your passive vocabulary and the
passive vocabulary does get activated as
long as you speak at some point you have
to speak however it is amazing how much
you can learn just through a very
consistent program of listening and
reading and someone asked as well here
do I listen repeatedly or repetitively
to the same material or do I read or
listen more extensively in order to
acquire Allah
vocabulary well initially in order to
become familiar with the language you
have to listen to the same limited
material over and over because you can't
even at first tell where one word begins
in the next word ends you have to get
your brain used to the language but
within a month or two I move on to
extensive because I want to cover lots
of vocabulary and you know with the
system like think I hate to always refer
to link but it's possible to deal with
vocabulary that has 30 or at least to
deal with texts that have 30 40 %
unknown words so I very definitely move
into a more extensive pattern of
listening reading with the goal of
building up my passive vocabulary that's
why I think the number one metric the
easiest thing to measure is the passive
vocabulary how many words can you more
or less recognize when you see them or
hear them in a given context even helped
by the context it doesn't matter because
all these words you're gonna see them
again and again if they matter to you if
they're important they'll come up again
or again if you are listening and
reading in an extensive way they'll keep
coming up you'll see them in different
contexts you'll gradually get a better
sense of what they mean and you don't
have to nail it down the first time you
come up against it and when you are
ready to speak and when you speak more
and more of these words will activate
naturally as you speak and I will do a
separate video on the kinds of things
you can do to help activate your passive
vocabulary to help yourself prepare for
speaking but you know the the idea that
as you start into a language you're
gonna try to speak the language to me is
is simply nonsense from a language
learning efficiency point of view it may
be what people want to do I have no
doubt about that
and most people are quite unsuccessful
at language learning when you basically
don't understand what the person is
saying you aren't gonna have a very
meaningful conversation and and if we
look at motivation and language learning
and I and I grant you that people are
motivated differently
some people simply have the motivation
to be able to say hello and and and give
the impression that they speak the
language in which case to focus on a few
key sentences and phrases and to be able
to trot them out is probably quite
useful however if the goal is to be able
to participate comfortably in
conversations or if you're in the
workplace again you have to understand
what people are saying if the goal is to
gain that kind of comprehension then you
have to focus on your passive vocabulary
now I'm not saying you have to know
every word in the dictionary but you
need a substantial vocabulary and it
doesn't matter whether you only count
words as word families or whether you
count every occurrence of the word the
way we do it link it doesn't matter it's
arbitrary it's it's pursuing this
passive vocabulary is a bit like I
compare it to the mechanical rabbit that
the dogs chase in dog races it's
something that you pursue in order to
build up that familiarity with the
language to expose yourself to the
language to build up your passive
vocabulary you know I saw a video on how
to motivate people because obviously
motivation in language learning is
extremely important and there was a
study done that showed that insofar as
motivating people to do tasks for very
simple basic tasks the more money you
give them the more motivated they will
be to do it move this pile of stones
over there as quickly as you can and
fastest person will get the most money
then that will work however if you're
dealing with more challenging tasks that
involve concepts and thinking and
creativity and so forth the research
showed that giving more money in fact is
counterproductive and that there are
three things that people are looking for
in these kinds of challenging tasks and
I would include language learning
amongst them number one is independence
in the workplace people want to have the
feeling that they control their
workplace that they do things that they
want to do number one number two is
what's called mastery the sense that
the challenge is something that you can
cope with just a little bit difficult
for you that as you're doing it you're
developing new skills you're you're
increasing your you're becoming more
powerful in terms of your abilities
you're achieving this mastery over a set
of skills at tasks and so forth so the
first one was independence the second
one was mastery and the third one was
purpose people like to do jobs that they
think are meaningful that serve a useful
purpose so if you can give an employee
the sense that they are independent that
they can achieve mastery over the
requirements of the job and that the job
that they're doing is important and
useful then that person will perform
better than someone who you just simply
reward with money now how does this
relate back to language learning you
know typically people say well you have
to learn English because you need it for
your job that's a bit like giving the
money on the other hand if you can
devise a language learning approach that
allows you to choose to learn from
things that are of interest to you so
you're not forced to study a specific
curriculum you're not forced to learn
parts of speech in the order that the
teacher choose to give them to you I
personally don't like that approach I
like to pursue the language on my own I
learned those aspects of grammar that
interest me when they interest me when I
come across them when I have questions
about them I study things that are of
interest to me so I have that sense of
independence in my language learning the
second thing is mastery if at a very
early stage you are confronted with the
task of getting your conjugations right
and getting your declensions right and
trying to find words and not
understanding what the person is saying
all of this is frustrating unless you're
in a situation with a teacher where you
don't have that independence and the
teachers just drilling you and you're
just a robot responding to these prompts
but if you want to be independent and
then you want to achieve that sense of
mastery
it is easier in fact to achieve that
sense of mastery by doing a lot of
listening and reading and watching your
comprehension
you're never confronted with frustration
it's a little bit foggy at first and
gradually following things that you have
selected that are of interest to you it
becomes clear and you have that sense of
achieving a higher and higher degree of
comprehension which is tremendously
satisfying and for most people who don't
live where the language is spoken it's
also quite easy to arrange and the third
issue is purpose obviously you have to
want to learn that language if you are
not interested in learning the language
again you won't have that sense of
purpose but if you are interested in
learning the language for whatever
reason which could include you know for
your job but might be because of our
partner wife husband friend interest in
literature culture history anime
whatever it might be so if you have that
purpose if you have an independent
approach to your learning and if you
have a sense that you are gradually
increasing your mastery these three
things are gonna keep you motivated so
those three elements I guess for the
person who is largely motivated to get
into that active vocabulary early could
also apply
I just feel in my experience that you
will never be in a situation where your
active vocabulary exceeds your passive
vocabulary you will always be in a
position where your passive vocabulary
exceeds your active vocabulary now there
could be situations where you have this
passive vocabulary it's so passive and
your listening skills are so poor that
you don't understand it when someone you
know uses the word in speech although
you may be able to understand that if
you read it and and this I mean there
are people who read very well and can't
speak but people who understand very
well and not just vaguely what it's all
about but who genuinely understand
clearly what's being said when the
language is spoken people who understand
that well and who have that kind of a
passive grasp on the language are going
to speak well if they don't speak well
yet it's because they haven't spoken
enough but if they decide to go and
speak with that kind of a grasp of the
language based on passive vocabulary
they will very quickly be
good active users of the language so a
bit of a long rant here on this whole
issue of active and passive vocabulary
thank you for listening bye for now